we have a very honorable guest making
the opening move there I will ask and
out of curiosity just who they were I
don't know if they were Norwegian
politicians dd for the yeah the
hardy head class has Wesley so open with
d4 okay so we saw a base game that we
played d4 yeah Bobby got a great
position now you know maybe add some
cooperation but yes well we got a great
position d4 is another move of course
because with actually with c4 you also
allow c5 right for example for example
which didn't happen in the first game d4
b 6 d4 b 6 and i think i think on the
wall right there was a projection of the
other game i think he was actually
checking on the approach being taken
between hominy and Caruana now this one
really seems to me that after the move
b6 is look looks like a little bit's
love like of games going on there which
the slop of course is in fabi's
repertoire before b6 it looks like this
is really giving Wesley an opportunity
to seize the center he's played 93 but I
really like c4 Knight c3 with the idea
of you know getting the wedge d5e
forfeit ok Knight c3 if Magnus plays the
move Bishop e7 and just for argument's
sake if I play the move f3 that's also
very possible no you really don't want
to play d5 but you want to stop me from
playing I want to I want to play e4 I
want to snub your butt now look what you
did why did you put your bishop
now c4 right
and then it's like nice a Queen's Indian
comparisons Magnus experts the bishop on
a six no that's that's interesting I
like that approach a little bit more
because also against Bishop e7 I didn't
have to play f3 I could have played c4
the move Bishop a six preventing me from
getting the wedge I want which is a d v
e4 right okay Knights - and to recapture
wait oh yeah well the reason I asked is
if I play E for here obviously the move
Bishop a six was sent there to disturb
me Bishop takes F one look takes F one
so if you still have this option piece I
see yeah I want to go Knight c3 Bishop
e3 castles and I'll develop my Queen
sees of you a 3a - yeah is that that
looks because Magnus has spent some news
trading a piece that's never developed
yeah so from that perspective Wesley
will have an engine development god
they're one of the things I wonder is
how early these guys are completely out
of their prep right I mean I know that
we've talked how much preparation is
probably the least the least important
factor in terms of who's gonna win this
Fischer random title but true but they
do spend some time they have to try
right and I think it was Bobby who
showed us some crazy lying with the
Queen a just amazing deep prep so it was
so crazy
my point is yeah so how early does
Bishop a6 get played and Wesley already
now at 42 minutes is like well I didn't
actually think about this move order I
don't like do you like this right i I'm
okay with it because I like to follow up
C d-four if it's in tension with b3 was
to play c4 I like it and that's what
because he's basically saying to black
hey look if your strategy of putting a
bishop on e6 doesn't pan out you know
why did you put your bishop on this
silly square so d5 III let's say
okay and okay
or maybe Bishop f4 first does it make
sense Bishop f4 also always a little bit
concerned that they should be for sure
yeah that's why I disliked b3 I am wait
it's coming more of like some sort of
almost ready
well it's really an Enzo Indian
Rubinstein's right like what we saw
Indian type of that's right Queen on a8
some health yeah but I can see black
playing for 96-95 like in nimzo-indian
style trying to eyeball the seat for
pawn but again if if black doesn't do
something of that nature
white gets to play Bishop e2 castles and
the bishop on each you will have a much
higher functionality than the bishop on
ASA yeah I agree with you that white is
fast actually in development and already
night is on g3 Bishop e2 Castle so I
think black really has to challenge
center ring otherwise otherwise if he
just tries to also develop I think white
White's white will get slight edge
weight will be fast exactly for
comparison's day let's see how this
position compares to the other a little
game here's it's ready for me with mad
just magical well I was gonna say it's
it's almost like the same type of
opening that this is like a closed
Catalans
some sort of position where White has
very big center over there in the game
between yonder palm Yoshi and Fabiano
Caruana good version for a white - a
good version for white White has
achieved the space that you often strive
for in those close positions and the
bishop and queen are sort of looming
there on that dark square diagonal to
eventually busts things open with and
move like d5 so I don't know I feel like
this is maybe gonna be the best game
we've seen you on play in a while right
now I'm liking
White's position a lot right there
enough for then Bishop Knight have for
probably just Bishop a big question
always and that in situ I would be a
little reluctant for be one because of
the Queen yeah I think it would be a
choice between c2 or an f1 right so
Knight f4 Bishop c2 would probably be
the way that game goes but I wanted to
say that man fabbi and an FSB cuz they
say those guys are in the middle game
deeply so and Magnus and Leslie are
still struggling on move three or four
to classical chess and classical chess
positions always big question is like
should I trade only for or should I
allow a five because there are some
lines when you allow a five and when you
then try to challenge it with f6 well
and also in a position like this if you
allow me five c5 becomes more
interesting right as then d4 can be
undermined and well the problem if we
make a bad move let's just let's make a
bad move rook on the fa2 e8 for just
gentleman then after e5 Knight d7 let's
say let me take on d5 and just see four
takes d5 c6 takes d5 so it might be my
opinion you have like the worst French
ever right because f6 very dodgy with a
ninety six point the bishop on b7 no
no no that's just like a bag so probably
black and allow this probably gonna have
to capture and if you capture an e4 by
the way I was thinking that the knight
on c3 would recapture and now suddenly
you really do have to be very very
careful the Queen on any one Bishop um
be to menacing
a very serious attack with d5 yeah and
now actually night on g3 is very good
piece because after we trade Knight f6
and 94 Knight h5 and d5 might be very
like White's pieces were meant to be
there it's not so random does it give us
new idea that maybe we can put in the
classical chest lines where we get such
positions Knight to g3 yeah that's an
interesting attack again you see a lot
of that right now with some different
approaches to the game of the highest
level which I caught up with Vichy at
the same feel Cup and we talked a lot
about alpha zero and he was talking
about some of the different things that
alpha zero is doing that had people sort
of doing some for each one that was one
of them talked about the King in the
center talking about different
evaluations in terms of the Knights and
how they play against the bishops and
stuff and so it's always exciting as
people that are chess professionals like
us to say hey there's a lot more to this
game and we're seeing completely
original approaches so I don't think
that's crazy to say like hey this is a
battery we've seen before but maybe
maybe with the knight on f3 is is not as
effective as you might think so
interesting yeah by the way shout out to
Matthew Sadler and his co-author yeah
game changer I brought it with me I've
been reading it in the evenings just
yeah when I want to nicely you know
learn to play like alpha zero
that's what did we do i he took on c4
recaptured Natasha Regan was the cop
thank you thank you for that and Bishop
takes c4 was very quickly recaptured by
yon and if I could ask you both wouldn't
you have at least if you take the move
Bishop takes c4 back at least consider
taking with a pawn oh no find me d4 no
my leg supposed to be on there
because there is no you're not wrong
there is 95 track tactics tricky I mean
I think probably it's dismissed because
he might sack the exchange somehow and
the bishop is defended by the night so
maybe I can even but I don't know
actually the more I look at it maybe
when I look at it yeah maybe it was
interesting as g7 is hanging I've opened
up the day yeah well I like karate five
more interesting okay but he did
recapture with the bishop he did it very
very quickly and after a six well I
wanted to ask for he had 85 and 90 for
God I wanted to say that after E 5 don't
play Knight d5 because I'll take on d5
and once again you have a terrible
terrible French and this is what fabbi
sought to avoid let's yeah and I really
he played Knight g4 okay is this not
gonna get chased back to what he wants
e5 as quickly as possible trying to
center first know for sure
yeah Age 3 is coming and I don't see
anything better than backing up yeah
okay in fact no it was not played Yan
has just played the move Knight CD pull
on the light board right okay this
Bishop sc1
yeah I will I also wanted but that maybe
then I ignore it and I play c5 after a
bishop c1 maybe idea with this move
either way he plays Knight C to e4 again
very quickly and that's exactly what I
wanted to say and if we Bob you know I
probably play c5 and ask questions later
look I don't want to miss my opportunity
to bring some Liberty to my pieces
exactly it's that yeah he does it I
would you just have to do it right you
put it on the board and if it's terrible
well then I'm Morgan loss has already
lost him again well do Bishop on b7 and
Queen Amy yeah they're desperate for
liberty well that's uh let's get back to
you so no sorry good no I I just wanted
to take it on c5 and just think what
kind of position problem yeah but you
know this is a little tricky and I guess
although h3 I can't take I'd have to
back up so it looks like yawns gonna be
playing with an edge here
if he can convert but it's time to go
back to the other board the marquee
matchup of course is Wesley so now
playing with the white pieces against
Magnus Carlsen if you're just joining us
everyone this is the second game of the
day here and the Fisher brand of chess
world championship they drew the first
game so the score is all knotted up at
one and a half games apiece because of
how the scoring works so Wesley so and
Magnus Carlsen are tied currently in
their in their battle for the first-ever
frfr I just want to say fr but I can say
Fisher random again a messy world
championship title yeah and I'm just
trying to guess myself how close this is
to a normal position after c-4 takes e5
e6 takes d5 upon c4 takes d5 Bishop
takes d3 rook takes t3e takes d5 f3 as
we saw Abby play in the earlier game of
the day can you just put that on the
board for a second because again this is
like vintage Michael bought Vinick and
Gary Kasparov followed him I definitely
I want to play efore and get very very
very much so it's very standard in those
positions to play like f3 Knight yep go
ahead f3 for a second just rookie ages
for a second Knight f5 Bishop birthday
right very standard in these kinds of
you'd be really shocked usually there's
a rook on a one by the way and but you
would late g4 like right here g4 rook a
to and rook g2 yeah and the rook and
somehow that's you know migrated over to
the Kings side and trust me when I say
you know a lot of grandmasters have been
victimized by White's attack it's not
that one of a lot of international
masters you have by the name so I'm not
pointing fingers you may be looking at
one right now no I I know exactly the
line you're discussing and it's a very
difficult structure for Knight f3
yeah I wanted to play it immediately
because then I keep an option if you
play rook e8 I can take it
Bishop III rook c1 and commented to the
f3 idea yeah so dual options take you
seven Bishop e3 or you can play a four
first because you're not really in a
rush
unless c5 is coming well I think the
main point is that we can visualize a
goal that if white is getting some sort
of complete bind over here on the C file
then you're playing with an edge for a
long time I think this is getting into
some trouble now having said that can we
start with a move like Knight b5 forgive
me for my Pontius over there that you're
just gonna go grab that pawn and and get
away with it well at the moment I'm
feeling good about a fork that exists
like 95 c6 Knight c7 is it oopsy-daisy
that's a that's a sometimes you defend
the pawn and forget that there's a fork
behind it exactly yeah so I'm thinking
that night you would go Roxy okay I was
going to take on e7 now gain a tempo am
Bishop a3 and I was trying to get a
quick strike against the c7 phone so
let's go rook c1 c3 did you even do this
right I saw 96-83 with you there's some
irritation going on here it's not it's
so Suffolk oh you said you think Magnus
is getting into a bit of trouble you
like that line specifically I think so
because it is of course very nice to
attack but on the other hand at night is
on g6 and it kind of defense and I don't
like to allow Bishop f8 and then I don't
see the point to attack because my
bishop is kind of out of clay on c1 and
g7 weakness is defended so I think this
is nicer way
you don't risk much because if you start
after a g4 then
ponts never go back and you might end up
in endgame where its weakness or
whatsoever but if you take Bishop then
we definitely see that Bishop is much
better than tonight
now Knight on g6 doesn't do anything it
cannot go to f4 can I go to e5 Knight h4
doesn't make sense another night on d7
is also not a nice piece it has to go
somewhere if it goes to f6 I can always
play f3 and if it goes to f6 then it
doesn't support c5 idea right so I
really dislike it for black this exact
position and I think that white has very
clear obvious play right before is in
and this moment by the way is very
standard in the Queen's Gambit and by
the way I think it's something we saw on
the Fabiano game where where white
somehow got in b4 8th and let's say it
was c6 yeah yeah yeah and a 6 C 6a 6b 5
by black okay so Magnus has played the
night of 16
it's funny because what you want to do
usually in these positions is why just
play d5 and a4 and then bring everything
every power and resource you can sit
down but there's a funny line B 5 a 6 a
4 a B don't play of all things
yeah you should pay 3 first ok ok but
it's a funny line but you're clean it
would be an important thing though that
I can't consider sacrificing the
exchange I guess I shouldn't okay
nevermind I thought I was getting a
little more than that but right the rook
would have to move and then we take back
and well that would be this is the ideal
for why I think you'd have to tie B Phi
B for Bishop takes before and then go
rookie 6 but aren't you surprised with a
very quick Knight of 6 yes
when Jerry c6 was also an option I
I would have definitely taken some time
I think just the idea is that I want to
play be 596 night beef se for today and
that's where I think also in Nepos game
it was like a four maybe be five at some
points where there's just meant by be
five anyway no but now if you play c5
and I will play c5 you yeah I agree
there's an isolated weakness you can
take on c5 right what you're showing and
I'd be forced to recapture with the
night and then my pawn on d5 is a yeah
long-term weakness right why you still I
think playing good be very careful
because I might have
yes yes just in time to be a little
careful deliberate but I the move Knight
f6 that was played so quickly by by
Magnus it's it's c6 yeah b5 c6
yeah you know I almost wonder if he's
sort of bluffing at the Kings side here
I mean this is the type of position
where you hope for an attack and some of
these Carlsbad pawn structures that's
exactly what black gets in a middle game
they play 94 you know there's often a
dark square bishop still that maybe
helps in that process the queen is in a
more natural position to join the Kings
side so those are the those are the ways
that can work out in an ideal world for
black but white is just so far ahead
here White has already got b5 right I
just I look at it revived by Magnus and
say I don't think that black is gonna be
catching up here well I you know if I'm
in Magnus shoes I feel that he's kind of
burned some bridges here and he needs to
play Knight h4 rook c6 in 94 and rook g6
justify yes that's a lot it's a lot of
Tempe but Knight age for rookie 694 has
to be what Magnus had in mind when he
played aged 5 because he's not doing the
H for H 3 H 5 does not necessarily mean
that I'm gonna do something there a
trial is just a nice move I'm having
space for my king and
I say that okay maybe I'm gonna attack
maybe not maybe I will try to regroup
first with 9f 896 King age 7 if you do
some kind of a 3 maybe I will think of
g5 rook g8 I don't know okay I think
that all sounds fine but it's like super
slow what do you do Bishop III know it's
rook c7 okay rook c1 ring more let's say
Knights effect I'll take that guy you
guys always put I agree with the idea on
a plan level but like every calculation
White is like way ahead here
the lineup of people here run it won't
want to join Dani and I let's meet up it
was on me who played age five this was
really funny I was playing bughouse with
LaVon and LaVon partner was playing very
poorly LaVon was getting killed because
the part was playing game it was playing
poorly and I said to his partner Miguel
you know the three of us all of us we
will beat LaVon like terribly back and
the ones that I you started crying
position your same situation you're
playing alone I would love to be with
white but I have to try to find
something we're trying to justify h5
hard to justify Knight f6 so quickly and
then h5 that was the point and we're not
obviously we've seen Magnus Carlsen make
all of us look like fools on a regular
basis with areas he comes up with so but
again looking at this position Wesley
taking some time here but I don't think
this is the you know we see the very
focused look this is not the focus look
of being unsure I think he's really like
feeling like there's an opportunity here
this right that's right that's right
and again we're thinking that Wesley's
bishop on c1 being passive on this
know we could jump with a tempo to a
three which he did not do by the way and
play we're gonna stage threes he just
basically said okay I want to stop it H
for H relaxes and maybe there was an
opportunity for black in some distant
world I'm not sure how he's gonna do it
but to play Queen B Aiden Knight g4 so
Wesley said okay if I play h3 first tell
me what you're going to do it's useful I
I thought bishop see Bishop c12 III was
that's exactly what I mean that Magnus
he played h5 which does not directly
indicate that I want to attack but when
you play h3 then if at some point I'm
able to put Queen a five-night of fate
Bishop 96 and g5 then you would love to
have pawn back on h2 because g4 is
coming no the line you're highlighting
is is now we're looking at a traditional
sort of qgd Karlsbad structure where if
you give black just a couple moves right
if you give black Queen a five
okay maybe not 94 but what up what can
happen in these lines is at some point
if the sixth rank is clear there's
there's ideas with rook lives I mean
there is potential here for the King to
get in trouble with so many pieces on
this side of the board line now I'm
taking on c6 hello what are you doing
yeah maybe queen up five maybe I just
ignore okay okay now comes the question
let's go with what Queen takes c6 okay
Queen takes c6 I'll go fishing up that I
don't want to go with your queen of five
so let me just give up the C pawn yet
okay C takes time so that means that my
queen of file was not completely
ridiculous you're just giving me a
passed pawn that's all I'm a little
nervous
I'm fine with it I can take back with
rook c7 or whatever okay so maybe queen
bee one okay
Knight h4 night h4 oh okay now I just
want to check maybe I him once and he
dreaming late
you played the queen of okay it would be
interesting here if I'm either getting
made it or I'm winning that's how it
works okay okay so he definitely wants
to recapture obviously with the rook on
c6 makes perfect sense because the open
C file your books belong into putting
files so a funny long yes sir is Bishop
III to these rooks e6 with might be five
because don't play a six okay
I'll pop in there but you can play
Knight d5 there directly now instead of
Bishop c1 Bishop III mean well then
display so if in this position night b5
then there is the movie yeah the reason
I wanted missionary three verses because
I really am really just trying to
complete my development so I can get
over here okay so
and I thought of rook c6 Knight here and
if you are forced to play some move I
wish this is just a line up that's right
I'll play rook c4 okay you're gonna
defend her 96 96
thank you six okay so I was thinking you
would play some move that avoided
independent and then another challenging
right make sense by the way I mean his
Mac I mean this would be amazing
better because then if you take
everything of play Brooksie at have
Brooks III in the end and I'm still
better on you you're happy to trade off
the heavy guns this would be amazing
idea if Magnus plays for example in this
position after what did you want Bishop
a3
imagine Magnus played Knight e4 or so
because 9h for or night six what's wrong
with that
nothing all you need is one Chapman
linen Oh 100 Carlson's pulse went up to
almost 100 this is unusually high for
him his father Henrik has said this on
NRK that he he must have discovered
something he didn't like so excited so
it makes the guy I think that's
excessively pessimistic I think that he
has to take the optimistic approach that
he's saying they're looking so let's try
it a line for white for example Bishop
III 984 right exactly
Bishop III 9 h 4 or 94 but night h 4 and
the idea from blacks point of view is
rook c1 no no age for 1984 this is my
plan oh thank you and Knight e4 and
Magnus is losing on the Queen side no
question about it but rook g6 may mean
anima checkmate
with you know well pleased to say that
Queen h3 exact exactly exactly so that's
reacting to the potential of this attack
with f3 that's very nice about it I
think that has actually somehow
justified but then it means that Wesley
has messed it up a little yeah that
means that maybe even taking c6 was
actually wrong right he should have
better if he was going to play with f3
he should have started that way just
left right attention situation like this
it makes I mean even makes more sense to
just build up on the tension you've
already established your right of you
know before having to commit and help
think black Courtney because I assume
Agnes will now take with the rogue in
fact look he's just done that he took
with the rook and now all the sudden it
seems that the C file opening has by the
way it means also that not only this is
black the one who took advantage of the
opening on the Queen side
but he hasn't sacrifice I mean h5 is a
kind of a funny movement he hasn't
really sacrificed and the movie 3e4 by
Wesley I think that it's necessary
because if you don't play this then why
did you play up three just made a
weakness on g3 for knows he's come a
completely different game than what we
thought we were headed to her yeah it's
like a dominant bind on the C file right
positional grind it's more dangerous
than the actual right the idea you
definitely sort of got so to take the
bait whether it was a real threat or not
is still unclear yeah I I thought it was
very interesting quite of magnitude
funnily enough this is has echoes of the
fabbi game with a a B one with white
yeah against yon with this efore idea
and now Wesley obviously Wesley to move
Bishop g5 is a monstrous threat and
Magnus has to deal with that yeah I
think actually Wesley took very nice
approach not to not to go bishop a3 and
95 because maybe he would have something
on C filed maybe not but this is like
this is more active this is like more
concrete right and there is some very
concrete lines coming up because after
d5 take c4 obviously white desire is to
play f3 takes e4 you have to analyze the
ramifications of Knight e5 and these
lines are going to be very sharp if you
put that on the board for a moment Danny
95 so the idea is obviously you can take
on e5 + f6 the graves may be right c1
hanging I don't believe
I like rook g3 and g4 and 95 threatening
97 don't want this 95 95 Queen t4 I
don't know what's going on you're okay
pause pause because you're not are you
threatening Queen - I'm afraid of 97
checked that's absolute that's a real
hit like a heart attack
you're attacking dd4 but c1 is hanging
yeah but then both Knights are hanging
as well if you take them d5 can't we all
just get along
so Knight takes d5 Queen takes d4 yeah
let's take c1 queen e5 actually I wanted
to play King gauge still unbroken but
then you have Knight f6 oh okay perhaps
unnecessary but hold on so this is this
is the line let's remind everybody
looked like the line position we're
analyzing to start from weight 95 was
just plate so oh wow it's now the light
position that we're analyzing for that's
what I was saying it this is like really
really sharp stuff so sorry so because
you wanted chief oh maybe Knight d5
right away Wow
holy smokes nineteen forty five seventy
seven is he right it's like he's a
meaning for the night
Oh a while blue I didn't see 95 95
there's a crazy move and it might be
just good enough no he doesn't see it
but 95 5 the idea was again buddy you're
hitting the pawn and hitting 97 97 95 85
93 and
but this is just okay so it was the war
okay yeah just an idea
yeah and he didn't play rook g3 with
those ideas of Bishop h6 and rook f6
played rookie three and now well we got
to ask the question rook takes the view
or 95 move what does he see on the rook
well for I think he is intention if you
put it on the board Danny is rook d4
Knight night before I did Oh II five is
hanging but then c1 is also hanging so
these are both moves by the way because
night b5 hit seven yeah but no seven
hits seven square no but there's a
knight b5 rook d7 okay sorry so go at 95
right Knight takes d5 ETS gives a bit of
a ah Knight takes e5 e 65 65 rook takes
e5 the end of the day c1 is hanging and
black is better so your move Knight d5
it's better yes yeah buy a new was okay
I'm hitting a 7 if you play rugby 7 I
want to take here Brooke see why I
wanted to believe it was good maybe I
should play like a sufficient B - yeah
yeah but there maybe for coming that's
ok that I can live with click your heels
together all you have to say is I
believe there's no place I can take on
me - you should you should eliminate
that very day he never believes my
tracks nobody believes nobody believed I
believed that you know Stevie she had a
notebook strange rook takes d4 Knight e
to a ha double attack and defense
everyone yes there you go that's the
trick but then why look III because of
rookie for them we don't we sell the
mystery we sell so now rugby 3 no longer
strange that'll teach me for trusting
and reading the chest Eve each other
now rookie three makes sense yeah and
again everybody to translate our line
further the threat is 92 which wouldn't
work if the rook was on g3 because
because I could take hitting the knight
in defending e5 from the Queen stare
smarted that that's really cold it's
good you guys I feel good there but it's
such a difficult move not only rook t4
but Knight see for ease with tempo
although if you play 94 then I go rook
g3 and I'm so happy exactly because
you've you voluntarily closed off the C
file and maybe a good defensive Knight
is now gone off astray I think you last
game or eventually it seemed critical
and kind of tedious there as the opening
went to the middle game but then
Magnus's dark square potential was
probably even more than he realized in
the game right with the attack right you
start to feel maybe similar things here
right donate one there's some dark
scorpion my goodness he did play Knight
c4 I think in the rookie three surprised
Magnus is still an f3 as well which is a
double rook yeah threatens e5 it's also
interesting along with Bishop c5 Wow
along with Knight d5 and I go my diva
will takes d4 now rook takes d4 or let's
have a look see what takes deep 95
that's the move that I'm going to read
about right I'm gonna take it yet with
my looks poised to f7 yeah it's actually
yeah I'd be very
oh my god oh my god scary move okay here
for 95 trick or treat
yeah trick or treat rope tasty for I
don't get it but I'm I almost don't want
to analyze I just wanna hear the real
board right now like what happens next
as Wesley is looking well think about
how many pieces Wesley has is the Queen
on a wand is an attack everybody it's
that's on that long diagonal its
eyeballing f6 Angie said that's great so
can we look at 95 go ahead and put it on
the board for a second also if I've
might be interesting yeah very good 95
okay but this one threatens 97 sort of
that defense here or something or maybe
more nights of 6 maybe just looked for
Knight f6 a little nervous enough for me
to worry I would like to play rook takes
f6 and I'll tell you why because here
you don't have to capture on yes yes but
if I take with the rook and now I gotta
- yeah and then you bring my Queen into
the game right now I'm eyeballing Bishop
h6 and Queen f7 we'll see if Magnus can
defend the open King on the dark squares
you want a just joining us everyone in
Game one of this match we had a
two-on-one for black but an open King
Wesley so barely defend rookie 4 so
we're on the right day we're probably
about to see the same type of dynamics
where Wesley so is gonna blow open the
black King and see if he can convert in
the attack where Magnus field to do what
about Bishop h6 oh you're getting too
spicy but I like it the night is much
day has been yeah white is pinned that
is a tricky 100 then if you move the
knight rook takes up step yeah well this
Queen takes g7 mate
like you say the night here there yeah
of course of course
Bishop eight success that's so plays
Bishop h6 hold on but it does it for
they may not need you because his yessir
pointed out this variation we use
various forcing but Bishop is a six it
might manage that first of all yeah
Bishop g7 I just want to take exactly
but it also has the advantage that that
whole set up with Brooke at six now
works so much better yeah Bishop already
on h6 so Bishop h6 definitely feels this
is the critical moment yeah this is what
I'm also a lot of a lot of grandmasters
a lot of people ask the question what
why is one Grand Master better than
another
yeah at the highest most elite level
these boys have a sixth sense of the
critical moment yeah I think Wesley when
he played the move 95 had intended rook
f6 they thought I have great
compensation let me go for it and now he
gets here and he doesn't instantly play
the move like maybe never like I paid
six is just to move to consider
definitely because I also want Luke g3
after Bishop h6 force and by the way how
silly before non h5 suddenly looks yeah
but okay and by the way you see very
very low Wesley so as Bishop h6 I just I
just want to ask question do we see an
easy defensive move after Bishop h6 for
example is Queen d8 a possible answer
yeah very nice Bishop h6 Queen d8
because the trick is that if you play
Bishop g7 then I can go Knight d5 cuz
you can't go Queen g7 eight anymore
right rook g3 okay let's go ahead Bishop
age six
tea eggs rook G 3G 325 rook g7 and Rho
cap six this is crazy I was gonna trade
Queens I hope with green before yeah yes
let's be sad so your take take no you
take take and Queen D for right
absolutely the same ending is it yeah
but I have a seven for now and ace a
seven but it did this their game with
one another key moment look at sex or
Bishop h6 you wish you know Brooke f6
may just be better really because after
Bishop h6 dude but why not visually
avoid what's wrong with sex I have to
defend my moment okay
we weren't sure was the point is Bishop
h6 Queen da maybe there's something
better than Brooke g3 yeah if I take you
want it to take on d5 with the night
seven I have been wondering why yes yes
yes about six I think you jigs did I
think you did it
we're really just hearing that you got
the move right now he may lose in a few
moves okay but that was a what a crazy
shot that is Bishop h6 by the way just
because of a little lag between the time
we we speak at the time and we heard a
replay yes like
okay Bishop h6 and played on the board
everyone if you're just tuning in again
we're looking at Game two here in the
major random World Chess Championship
this has been thrown
the defensive effort in this move Bishop
age seven under fire hmm the score
currently coming into this game was one
and a half games apiece to remind you
the scoring system a draw gets you one
and a half points a win gets you three
points so right now they are deadlocked
at one and a half games apiece but
they've only played one game for those
of you that are new to the event and
perhaps just tuning in what about night
eat eight okay so that was the first
move we suggested but seven failed
because of rook up seven and rook age
six and yes and maybe ninety seven you
know what's funny is they don't forget
about slain seems like second than queen
bee one queen c5 chairs if I've checked
once again very good by the way at the
end of that line I take he ate your
Brooklyn okay your rocket there's no
tree there's a night D - yeah there's a
possibility I thought Queen d8 was let's
say solid but maybe I have to take it
back I wasn't quite sure it's so solid
one question is whether you can take
first and then play rook takes us okay
but wait Bishop g7 means you've got no
threats on me right currently right can
i play rook no what am I saying Queen H
so rook g6 with the idea of Queen C fine
but I will play Bishop f6 Bishop before
I will point and then rookie - rookie -
barely
seven is held by them it's weird to find
something you know this garbage neither
for it's garbage cause dazzling
brilliance baffle
BOPE odd Bishop a6 looks fantastic
although if 98 works then you're really
gonna regret that you didn't blow this
thing open when you had to cheat with
rook have sex is that no but it cannot
work
come on he took a lot of time on it so
he we should be giving so the benefited
out that there's something here for
white of 98 98 is it rookie three I was
thinking about twenty three but that'd
work Jesus rook age six okay the whole
point of 98 was the Brooklyn c6 now
defending yes right across the sixth
ranked sorry yeah and this 98 reminds me
of a I had a game against John van de
Ville and a friend of mine from Seattle
Bob Garcia had come and we kept saying
9898 defends the game and Bob after what
says what's 98 1 less than 99 the chess
game can I ask what just happens after
98 Rukh f7 yes ok 6 and I just I just
take my time and play King h1 I know
that's very very crazy and it it's you
think I'm Michael tall you make
sacrifices you are 97 I want to play we
can bring the other rook into f7 or
is the other move I wanted to space
instead of King h1 but okay 25 to 25
then f8 yes attack d5 but you can also
something will be definite you do you
can do up your queen for 2 rooks here I
don't know if I like that well at the
moment I got a piece as well so I'm
giving up my queen I know that's what
I'm so I don't want this anymore
yeah a lot what if I play it's a trick
and bring the other rook in do you have
a threat to the 8 if you got ok Queen c5
is a hawk Osito defy Miss Caroline
Wright can f7 is hanging so don't take
on e8 I'll take on f7 yeah I think you
just came up short on this one no I
can't believe that there is nothing
after 98 let's put your not now you're
not resigning this not you know not
stand yeah what do we go back to Bishop
g7 what was the end of the role of this
here we're already 6 looking at what's
the threat of c5 and winning the bishop
correct something about this just seems
highly playing Knight takes g7 no then
you have a knight f6
yeah ok so I have like f7 going but
Queen c5 is always a bit of King H 125 a
rook f8 and rookie chase me oh so wait
what was the problem
yeah oh yeah it's a seven rook f7 and
then what check on c5 sorry but I'm
threatening day to night night takes g7
rookies six but I can play Knight f6
directly a bit I think
me too I think this works we do have 90
a 10-9 Bishop g7 played I like it 7 was
played instantly it took us this was the
first movie suggested that's right and
it took us coming all the way back
because we went everywhere after you and
we didn't come back to it okay Wow crazy
moment right now this is amazing you
know when you think a World Championship
title being up for grabs
yeah this is the type of contest you
want to see you
Rises the very game you want to see this
is not a definitely draw this thing out
to go to go or 12 games right this is X
Y I mean if you're a chess lever this is
this is as good as it gets this is
fantastic
Wow what it is you say so he must be
sorted already and I think it it seems
straightforward now that rook takes f7
is a huge threat because of the threat
everyone that rook will come to f8 and
then it will come to H a with meit
a lot of positions the f6 square has
become
for business now the g7 part is gone no
matter it works or not we have to say
that Bishop h6 and Bishop g7 by Wesley
so is brilliant because if Magnus did is
we would be like oh you know that Magnus
and we would believe it right away that
is h6 Bishop g7 Magnus tells us he's
gotten up from the board Wow he wants to
play Knight f1 in this okay
maybe h5 is suddenly looking brilliant I
mean my head is I'm shocked
I'm stunned by how smooth no but I will
I will play rook F forward you would
please it's about a 72 right attention
497 I went right but do you want to do
it okay so let's do it
rook F for right now you can't play rook
takes that fork because of rook c1 check
right so you have to think right and you
don't have time for Queen b1 check
either you can't even do it no but yeah
ah booty okay okay something connected
connected to that so one idea is the
move Bishop e5 to cut off the rook from
he's seven
okay f3 is hanging with check that's the
problem with you take with the no
because that's how you can lose your job
yes you go something like this and then
the Queen comes in and you goes oops
and whenever it comes to e2 and that's
you lose if you play rook g3 a knight of
one Bishop e5 Knight G 397 that doesn't
bring much you get a lot of material
yeah but maybe a queen bee one and
Knight has to go back well your Bishop
on e5 is of course attacking gene
Rosi 192 Roxy 182 here correct
Roxy one turns music on the spot there's
a lot of family Royal fork sorry yeah
okay so ninety-two hole I mean if if you
hadn't of you his ability to find that
move here I mean again right Marcus this
makes you a true chess fan obviously we
don't have an engine in front of us and
I don't want one right right this is
just no this you wanna calculate or you
can sound all the lines
okay how about bit no I was about to
suggest a move like Bishop c3 Knight f3
rook f3 and just play down the exchange
down the shaft with the open file but
I'm afraid rook g6 can you can defend
every us the sixth ring and that's
unfortunate just a second oh God C
Magnus kind of taking a look around so
well good zonin time on the clock is 20
minutes the other obvious movement I can
rook takes f7 can we put that on the
board for just said I think it has to be
Knight up one yeah and then rook takes
f4 because I have to defend against rook
c1 and the point is I can't just take or
maybe I can because of Knight f6 Chen
right but I'm up a piece oh shoot you
certainly are
oh no no no no this is good enough for
advantage black young yeah typologies d2
is quite the move
doesn't make a difference rook of
seven-night f1 rook check AHA king h7
does this line make a difference it does
if you want to play Queen b1o you also
have check and rook h6 check by the way
I don't know if that matters it does
because oh and agree to the F all you
take up over check but you had don't you
have to go to the F file don't tell me
you're gonna go King g5 what happened
okay yeah rook if seven he's on the
board and he's going to play FA check
there's no question this is what Wesley
so this line we're looking at okay check
that King comes to h7 oh yeah I'm
intuitive this was what Wesley had in
mind
okay Jade but is he right no he 585 Oh
what is he what
he's threatening check and then 97 in
the game is it maybe but rosie was broke
c1 well no first of all with rook c1 my
queen is defended yeah but I can go 97
checked right well not right away so
rooks e1 rook h8 check King g6 97 97
night Bishop takes and and I haven't
lost at a 70 whatever happens
big applause to the play this is
wonderful whoa but rook c1 might be
forced I don't see you know I mean rook
h8 or 97 threatens mate 97 it would be a
made on agent I love Roxy why Brooksie
197 but then tonight's tea somewhere
don't you shush your mouth and - about
what - it do it just do it just do it
put it on - crazy
nice having a discover check or take my
queen if you want discover check I run
yes but then I had this move yeah it's
raw classic that was that was fun that
was amazing unless there's something
else here that we know blue is there
something else here oh there's what you
ain't by the way that's a good starter
and then what happens at me
well h4u Shack does that make any snow
yeah there's a weird weird loose to
consider oh wow I like that Wesley just
took all ideas we said and she kind of
combining the what a twenty minutes
crazy Magnus but it's it's insane they
should be five Wow
well first of all this ninety to look at
seven this whole rook sacrifice by
Wesley Magnus provoked at all of course
Wow yeah it should be five what it's not
Brooke c1 I mean that's what I'm
thinking um if you don't have make c1
you'd be toast oh by the way can we just
see it again Rick see one rookie eight
king g6 night check no I could check you
with my rook before taking your also
Queen Queen C for fun yeah just trying
to confirm all possible checks all right
that was a check I don't know that it
really matters I kind of like my figure
might go go ahead rook h7 check I'll
tell you what King I'll take
Queen and that gives me the opportunity
to play rook e7 check aha before
recapped well I was going to capture the
rook on a1 and you're threatening rookie
seventh that was what I was along with
this and this right along with the night
no I'm thinking the night on f1 is
hanging so in this line you don't have
rook e1 because I have so it might mean
you have to play King g5 which is very
no no no none - stop stop stop stop
because rook g8 Shaq where is your king
go and see the mate here because if
Knight f5 King age 7 your best is to
just check and go right back no what I
wanted to play actually eight h4 can we
try h4 so yeah so you want a mate I I
don't know let's see I'll just somebody
made me I can't do you know there was a
an absolutely unbelievable genius his
name was Nash Medina and this would be
but I'm gonna make it not a game right
because Bishop e5 is good where do you
go Bishop g5 is coming yeah and then
it's me yes so I have to go back and
then that reship see what yeah bishops
do one and then that's it it's ball game
Jonny boy okay so H four would force
rook takes rook takes yeah okay now your
rook has been distracted now for my next
trick watch me pull a rabbit out okay
kicks is forced oh when they do okay
Jade yeah okay so if I go kini seven
rook here and if I go here is your peb
six basics yeah Oh brilliant
a line of clouds oh wait is this is this
just a forced mate never seen one rook
chatting she's 697 so you have to go to
f7 them because again if King g5 were
utilizing or might lead to a check
making takes this is actually very
forced right this is just made because
we will we pick up everything with
discover checks and it's yes that means
you have to play but then again rook g8
and we had to move beautiful missing h7
mate and M King to the G file that
brilliant Bishop h6 and Queenie and man
if King of seven that looks like it's
kind of forced right King a seven and
this is where we kind of went route
check and it was a really funny
variation King and we were taking the
Queen nothing better here I don't think
look at here you can't check on the diag
there are no reinforcements being
brought without helping black coordinate
it's there so you kind of have to just
take right and then take you the green
is the only move and this move says a
line takes f1 rookie seven shadow so the
night lots of time say it goes here o
way you can just check because King up
five there's rookie 896 Oh could you
King
Matty said it wins and the whole thing
Wow
King t5 said after rookie ssangshik yeah
okay King d5 no so I guess it would be
wonderful it was an echo but I can I can
take on 87 there's one oh that's a true
one yeah yeah okay before you checked
you could have also played King f2 okay
as a just a kind of a temporizing I just
like them
yeah no I'm guarding everything that
maybe we have something more on king f7
okay let's see we have been playing rock
h7 you mean Queen a to check yeah but we
might be for no Queen a to quincy for
Queen F to check
yeah so wait
yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes
are you sure I'm chef they block and you
have Queen - f - I think Magnus just
kind of leaned in yeah kind of being
aware that he's probably starting to see
some of these very a look at for maybe
yeah looking for King e6
queen of five born the problem is that's
actually not bad because Bishop might
night the 93-94 jaw drop perpetually
9300 before you could land the Desai's
this crazy okay love it close but no
cigar
oh you're not but still like let's put
Queen a one back on the board for a
moment yeah and let's see if we have
something what a variation what in an
analysis you know one thing I really
like okay like if we blunder pieces we
get to take our moves back those guys
every move could be decisive and again
three points up for grabs right this is
the slow rapidly but what's a line like
Queen
quincy for queen after rook F for I mean
seriously seriously it feels like some
kind of problem study mmm wait wait wait
my and maybe I can take I use definitely
the current position is Magnus did not
yet play Trixie one sorry
current position is actually right here
still we thank this rook c1 which leads
to enormous complications if I'm in many
others thank you that's what I want to
say I am looking for just a safety
escape hatch like takes our okay now
right away the rook is there what is our
threat White Queen takes rook a trade
and 97 yes rook 88 97 is it's accurate
that's the most direct and I would also
suggest that Queen takes f1 is a kinda
progress did you play a move like 27
then you're no longer threatening rook
c1 yeah well at Queen d7 I can also I
don't know Magnus has moved oh my god
rook c1 rook c1 and variation so we have
it we have it there was no other option
because I'm g5 was walking and to a
chariot as you showed why now I think
this is the moment you play rook h7
check is there another choice Queen a to
check we thought made it wrong right
yeah Queen Knight to Queen C for Queen
after rook F for Queen a for Queen F for
Bishop f4 doesn't pretty good that
Leslie is just we've seen this way uni
one minutes down to nine minutes on that
move the critical moment this feels
again it's like boy how many how many
times am I gonna say this is a key
moment yeah it is I'm sorry I don't
think my time brought to you by I don't
know
doesn't work okay then we have to
probably go into that and the game which
is not bad news
rook h7 but when you have such position
the problem is that you're you burn your
time to find mate
exactly you and really it just it one of
the things I think that these elite
grandmasters love seriously is the
beauty price and if you're Wesley right
now and you're thinking to yourself oh
my god maybe playing the brilliancy of
my lifetime the human nature do you
place over look at checkmate right I
mean how sad it would be if the moment
you get up from the board the arbiters
maiden board there but it wasn't there a
14 checkmate and 14 but you overlooked
Magnus is uh soaring and deeply here I
don't see a better move than rook h7 can
we just see this endgame line again rook
h7 my question was whether even have to
play Brooke h7 by the way but okay let's
go with this submitted to the endgame
you right they want to get the King into
a vulnerable position right what was the
night so we were looking at King e6
night c8 rook a one to ship a one by the
way we have a move it was broke a seven
so once again we're on the right track
looking at this line yeah so this exact
moment the knight on f1 is hanging it's
that simple
so it's Knight d2 or night g3 now Knight
g3 I think it makes the most sense just
from the perspective but it guards h5
you always have those outside chances
against the king yeah also you want to
play h4 maybe Rocio works hard not to
not to unless we see at home in this
movie right yeah okay now King f2 age
for my right and thinking that or you
you could play Knight f5 as well sorry I
9f5 probably or h4 but then I want to
take rookie seven even this like that's
it
oh maybe Roque four no no no okay four
there's also okay for instead of nine to
five we're about to see King George III
and I have rookie seven I'll take your
night that's very nice
looks like night take C it has been
played and we're gonna get all the
variations we've been looking at here
the only question is will Wesley because
we have some others the gem here I don't
think so yeah taking a one is logical I
just so hopeful Wesley say that there
wasn't some unbelievable yeah Wyatt move
meat sacrifice sacrifice I mean that
would just be you know not insane but
that would be just like so unlucky to
have missed it because of a rapid game
so Bishop a one on the board no we
expecting either 92 or 93 which it's got
kind of funny move if you go 92 and I go
right XP 7 back to Drew K 4 because now
okay for we could've actually okay for
actually solves the problem of
everything yeah right it stops rookie 7
because if you know because a Bishop h8
because Knight is hanging on f1 and
there is no Brooke a1 so nice that would
be a blunder right there in moments like
this I've rewind it a the line that the
Cle von Schaack said to me when he came
on in a commentary during a vikon's a he
said any good grandmaster would see
right away with Bishop of course you
play vision a she any good Grandmaster
would see it right away
I would respond I'm not a grandma and I
appreciate the respect the seal Wow
okay they are in this ending and it is
still I think Magnus in trouble I mean
there's a lot of black units on pre here
they have gotten themselves in a decent
position to make time control everybody
with 11 minutes to 8 respectively only 7
more moves to mate which will probably
see a couple forcing moves here so
likely bill they'll reach the 40th move
and get another 15 minutes
kind of expected - I like King Gustav I
do - something feels right about that
move I mean well it's taken you you get
out of the rookie one check we are
allowing King up to h4 I was going to
take upon on a 7 because I'm a bond
graduate but basics false as well well
then I am hurry up on driver in that
case of you I can do both Wesley
probably calculating whether it's
worthwhile to check give check and get
the rooks off the board you do go up a
pawn but probably with such a
centralized King for black you don't
have good winning chances but right away
ok but then rookie 1 I can get oh yeah
right that's just as straight as well if
not why do I live
ok this was hanging but you're you're
now threatening this rookie 1 we
anticipate King F 2 here or Bishop to
see no Bishop c3 would allow rip c4 c4
yeah yeah you can give 2 is nice wooden
a piece that would be like horrifying
you really the game of your life in
three moves in for should be Jade as
possible okay but I definitely like king
of - I want to get out of this age for
night jump three
mating
Nantz that we're so familiar with so you
can also play king h2 in a sense that if
what if black really starts to spend
their time on h4 there's still a few
moves away maybe there's something you
have if you can although it's very very
dangerous young in both games they do
the same it's like great attack and then
we go to end game exactly Magnus if
you're just joining us ultimately had a
very very dangerous attack may have
missed a winning game won obviously
we'll have a news report afterwards so
if you're tuning in and really curious
check that out at just calm slash news
but either way it also meant when a game
were so held to draw and now we're an
end game and maybe Magnus will hold the
draw as well but King f2 first these are
better winning chances maybe than what
Magnuson exactly that's what I want to
say my first take is that King f2 is
very very promising endgame advantage
again because why are we wasting time
but Wesley is playing so good I mean
he's defensive skills and attacking
skills the combination it's just amazing
today yeah he's really been on and on
his been firing on fire I'm still not
quite sure why King f2 was not shows was
he afraid of rook afford Shaq and the
king but now if he wants to take Knight
b6 ok key to this is the issue Knight b6
h4 yeah maybe this is this is why you
would have played King F 2 piece I see
ninety six ninety three I think is it 93
yeah because there's no more 97 check by
the way yeah but then Bishop d4 and
- or rook Jeets rook g2 and rook g3
sorry can we put that on the board yeah
let's do it
ninety six ninety ninety degree g4g and
now and rook g3 rook g3 rook geometry
and that's that's a big hit on H against
h3 chief for really an ex clam I mean
what's the idea on 93 how is it well 7
is available for business what sizes hey
what a move actually that's like is that
kind of obvious no well now if I trade
in the egg taken be six as well yeah
because now a seven is just available
but then he will trade one if he will
sacrifice okay so the point is the
knight on f5 can't simply move away
Magnus is now under five minutes to
figure this out now he will get he will
get fifteen more minutes and more move
forty I just got to play four moves
after Knight h4 rookie seven check as a
skier yeah if you if you stop the skier
with Knight e3 rookie seven check just
simply wins the night on e 8 I don't
think there's any perpetual for pets
yeah this looks this looks go no
although there is a check and then a
night check if it a check runs into king
everyone he plays 93 we're gonna find
out we're in this line oh my god sure
it's either winning four so or Magnus
has some very very cheery drawing
swindle up his sleeve yes window asleep
Wesley looked across the board at Matt
is there like like I don't see what's
wrong here I'm gonna take your piece and
ninety six also with check his head
check okay let's talk to King age one
look at you okay but that's just a piece
he's just down a piece might be six with
check ID basics check
well Magnus is completing the gun so
takes a breath which is smart when
you're kinda nervous and surprised a
game is uh oh my god has
has given you the piece on e7 and and
wowzer and they could see and if it's
the position I think they're getting to
it's a night which can anchor back in
but what does this end drawing what is
the drawing pattern I mean what you want
is black as you want a rook at night
versus looking night right that you you
want the a pawn no you want look at
night versus rook rook night and pawn
versus rook right good night and pawn
but okay well let's do it
rook takes III yeah check King G to rook
takes Knight takes b6 King c5 so what
you want is something like where they go
a5 and your knight is Miss place
remember we saw a game again the pom new
Yoshi versus this year not Magnus
Carlsen versus circa karyakin from the
world champs similar yet the the night
couldn't coordinate two guards aren't we
a piece up white white to take look III
okay see nicely six right away what do
you want generally I may want to go here
same game 85 okay you're just giving the
defendant oh okay yes yeah yeah okay you
want to keep so your point is well there
is no reason to train in the brook and I
keep the vision which is by the way a
pretty good piece
yeah it's a very good news yes it is but
remembers I'm just gonna say that well
it's a piece and a pawn okay there was
be very very clear that if okay so this
is the Magnus has played rip g4 rookie
the players have to move 40 that is why
we have more time we just took on either
he goes for it yeah it goes but yeah you
may be right in the end if there's some
awkward weird corner but so is lately I
think he killed
that is winning okay so the variation I
think Wesley is calculated as king g2
rook h8 Knight b6 king c5 III think
that's what Wesley has my cutting off
and help at the King yeah
there is an oka which is important very
important no rookie a rookie six ideas
yeah that is true okay there is this
move and try to get to 87 with a similar
but I can bring my King first I mean I'm
not doing the knight is this I've got
you now I've got you for sure rook b5
check King c6 Knight c4 ha rook to a7
Knight to a5 check and everything off
you cut him in everything is closest
this is really important than that you
don't want to push the pawn I think
that's where a lot of people game is
right the moment you push and you put
yourself in a position because I think
for a lot of our viewers they maybe
don't even know that again rook and
Knight versus rook is just a draw it's
it's a theoretical join now there are
some unique circumstances where you cook
there's a certain coordination you can
lose but theoretically with an active
King you should not be able to win so
really instructive to see how yaz is
kind of I don't allow this exactly on
that no to move I wanted to suggest
these years was actually the move rook
c3 to guard the night and then take next
but only because it cut off the king the
problem is for occasion sex it doesn't
work precise but I would but along the
same vein of I want to make sure this
King doesn't get over and that his rook
can't blockade but but again I don't
want you gave like it works just fine
yeah I suspect maybe knight c6 a king c6
sorry king c6 instead of king c5 and
what would be seven king gay six no c6
yes over here again now it's slow enough
that we try to get in don't go here yeah
can gifted
king of to okay
getting a six I made of money for those
who are curious is likely winning in his
game with five in a car wanna where we
apologize if if you showed up to watch
the I'm sorry you're at the wrong to go
right because we're on the edge of our
seats here with they have bid for
somebody but again you can go to chess
calm slash events you can go to chess
calm slash live on the phone you can
watch anything you want if you're using
the mobile app so you have plenty of
options to to watch the games if you do
want to choose your own adventure but
we're gonna stay right here Netflix we
have breaking back netflix Breaking Bad
binge watch exactly what I don't get
though is like why did you put yourself
in this situation yeah Wesley is
convinced he knows that this is a win
yeah then N equals four
right right all you need is one win and
everybody has their own style now I
happen to agree with Hugo that in this
case I would have liked to have kept my
bishop yeah me too
I I would think that it's much easier
and he is played by the way the move
rook III I know absolutely for sure that
Wesley calculated this is ready to meet
what was your age my age seven yes
I'm sure he's ready to meet rookies any
finite c4 yes but by the way I I just
saw there if I read him correctly
Magnus realizes is he just saw that I
yeah like yeah but was I was shaking his
head and it looked like he he was like
not satisfied but I know that was the
old always has shakes his head but when
he has also a winning position he's like
well there's like the 10,000 paces of he
Cara Nakamura and
I have not been able to decipher them by
the chef Stevie Chad made the same
comparison perhaps he's just trying to
play like a coral or look like a car but
again it really has been a fascinating
game over there between the palm neo she
and I marijuana it's just their bad luck
that they fireworks here we had this is
this has been I mean we saw game one was
fantastic
very well defended and Agnes barely let
it get away from it but this is on take
G seven ridiculously reactive we were
even analyzing lines with H four and the
bishop age sex queen h8 maybe that's a
commentators dream and I'm glad because
we managed to really find some amazing I
mean Gary yo Gary Kasparov would have
said hey I love this type of chess yeah
that's me up look at Wesley he knows
he's got the game in hand he just you
know it's two very very calmly you know
bring it home and that's the way if he
wins this one such a nice way to end
there is no more game okay that's it for
today for today today what do you think
don't scare the fans what I mean is that
if he wins this one and if we compare if
he won the first one and drew a second
one it would not be the same it's much
better to draw a first one and win and
then there is no more game because the
door thank you for coming I enjoyed and
by the way we highlighted at the very
start of the show that in their
individual matchups Magnus has actually
got a pretty powerful I'm not gonna say
monsters for but a pretty good a pretty
good one over all they just starting to
leave here with Fisher random yeah so
this is so chance to kind of write that
right that ship exactly
but what a game I mean seriously epic
it's amazing one of the best for now
this is a very easy win by the way king
c6 just to put a this because I think
this is a very important point king c6
Knight c4 king c5 there's no yeah it
doesn't matter king c5 Knight B to night
boy to avoid night boy - now you can't
touch the ball yes and I can't bring my
right that's right and now I can quietly
bring my king happily over to the Queen
side and escort the point home thank you
so the only chance Magnus has is just to
try to keep race yeah what you're trying
to keep this night on it I'll say
trading rooks doesn't help per se like
for example it doesn't help because then
I'd be - that's it
right yeah but still you have to
calculate their rights square now and
the Tempe that's it but okay so if it
was white hold on it the current
position is I'm sorry is a position it's
white it's black to play right so if it
if I'm in black shoes I'm thinking about
moves like rook h4 and let me just give
you an example of where it could go
wrong for Wesley King f2 rook before now
and now after rook takes King takes King
III King b6 that's that's why you want
your night on b2 that's why first there
would be five check King guess - okay so
and with the rook takes e4 I'll reduce
it for rook takes as much as a threat so
you have to bring your rib back to be
two now but thank you see 5:19 c5 again
and maybe
and there's still a threat abrooke
before but i think so but wait i will go
a five now okay maybe you should have
played a five before
well if you go to a five now can I go I
think it's weird
we just under I'm just trying to show
the pitfalls yeah that the end game has
now you can play yeah and would be six
check right so or or just rook be six
anyway no matter what this is the move
and then eighty six right now you're
getting the right setup with doing
heaven okay indeed Magnus has figured
out this is his best chance which is the
threat of rook to before everybody this
is the key right Wesley has I can go a
five directly yeah yes yeah that's what
I was saying the swords that 85 is
already possible yeah yeah and it's nice
or I guess yeah that's I agree because
you don't need the rook on the second
rank when the King is there or like
you're not you you're trying to stop
also ideas where the real comes behind
this is a fine square for the rook if
you just play a five I would say more
that it's important to keep King on c5
because if you give check and King c6
then you don't have Knight a for with
check because the King comes to ASA yeah
yeah in this line if you play rugby 5
and then rook back the point is that
King comes here yeah and he's walking in
front indeed ok so there's no reason to
waste time here but this is a very smart
move by Magnus because he's forcing
Wesley to find and okay he's played
would be five that could be a blunder by
Wesley why nobody's gonna allow him to
be seven no I think that's still okay so
for example King be seven I may get the
perfect set up again but night's
unfortunate your rook is on rook b6
check aha and before I get the or maybe
rook c6 either way actually as so long
as my knight is behind you as long as
you give a check action no matter where
the King
goes you can play Brooke before yeah
even on King age six you could have just
played it right away and then bring
bring bring king 85 and can gave for
exactly and away you go
okay so this is key rookie five rook b1
now that the rook is also not on the
second or third rank you're fine you're
threatening to rush the King no there's
no skewer which has been the problem you
can't just exactly you can't just run to
the Queen site and allow a rook h3 I'm
learning so much about chess right now
can I just share like I'm liking share
the happy middle school boy yeah like
this is just this is just so awesome
just to see that I'm telling ya sure I
feel like I should get out some popcorn
guys I don't even want to ice cream this
is so good if I was at home right now
and the kids are in bed it's like you
know get to make myself a bowl of cereal
don't you explain it to the kids
yes okay so Magnus has an idea Magnus's
idea is that after okay
hi ever five six correct yeah exactly
king of three rook a five and after king
of three Brooke a five if I go rook
before my fee I just want to show this
like yeah this is the problem this is
the issue precisely okay so if I go
after rook a five rook b4 with the idea
okay six and king c5 exactly actually
that's what I'm saying like but hold on
there's there's a problem
b4 right away now
so now you can't oh yes you can
we're okay 594 king C fine
and if I trade a five you get a for that
stuff that's a sweet I think that's a
pitfall that's what that Wesley has to
has to avoid it feels like he's gonna
hold 94 stops rook a five now if you go
rook HP's oversee but the one advantages
they can't occupy that square with both
piece exactly but also I think that with
the knight on c4 now I can
yeah he's played night c4 after king c5
I can also be five king c5 you just know
you have to play rook h4 I was about to
say I think I can just simply go rook c1
now you almost have night b2 here and
also austenite b2 b6
he's just gaining time but he's no this
is not oh yeah there's no increment
there's no game time no that's the
people commentator responses it's
gaining time of like no I think it's
night c4 rook age four night b2 right
away yeah okay can we just put that on
the body nice because rook before I go
rook c1 check and Alex e2 and that's the
setup I want they always just want the
nighttime beats ooh and I'm a hundred
percent sure I'm winning with an item b2
my real gun see - I'm a hundred percent
sure
oh wow Magnus is drawing this he's
trying his best to make it as difficult
as possible for Wesley and you got to
give Magnus all the credit in the world
for that I mean not only is he not only
is he always grinding you down but no no
no come on come on come on the said
Knights come on Wesley
why did Wesley come on six not a gain
another game I think Wesley was up a
piece against
and made a draw he's having some
difficulty winning games apiece up which
is a very strange thing normally his
technique is impeccable mm-hm
III think he will win this he's looking
a little frustrated a little kind of you
right now he's confirming lines again I
think that there was a Magnus Carlsen
circuit Kia karyakin I think it was
Games I saw a common in chat earlier as
part of the chrome neck from their world
championship match Kasparov saved in a
game okay doesn't come instantly to my
mind but okay that was 2000 yeah it
could also be the chat was wrong about
this 94 rook age for rook c1 rook if I
was not good it was 35 if I was winning
I think that's what I'm saying I know
what they were at the start of the move
so for Magnus it is accurate
obviously for Wesley it is he is
currently on the clock he had 15 minutes
and 12 seconds when it was his turn well
let's assume for a moment that Magnus
realizes he's dead lost that he is dead
lost right like and we can see his body
posture like as if he's he doesn't want
to give any tales to his opponent that
dude you're winning you know like he's
not putting on his jack and having some
kind of resigned you know I do that all
the time
half my game is and then you know it
shows a stalemate trick yes thank you
for is it it's easy
rook age for this is where we were easy
yeah rook before the rook c1 so the key
is this check followed by this move and
you're set up yes and then oh you're
right you just drag your king all the
way over to see instructive stuff that
yaz knows oh yeah no but wait a second I
have rook be thinking before King gay
three great
please might be too that's the wind and
Magnus knows that of course that's it my
car's gonna be tricky Magnus will claim
something and they always come to the to
the press conference afterwards why
didn't you play this move I wanted to
resign they never want to resign resign
but no this is this is the right setup
with the night on b2 I'm 100% sure yeah
and I remember there was a wonderful
comment that joel benjamin grandmaster
joel benjamin played Viktor Korchnoi for
the first time and Viktor went into an
ending that Joel really thought he had
some chances and so Joel said well why
didn't you just play this and win in the
middle game and Viktor said he's the
ABCs of Chad Russian school boys know
these things I don't what if I play King
b6 okay and I will play just for
argument's sake we'll see
and you will 1885 hopefully Rick see -
just just to let her have the gold
yeah just let's get it there let's go
I'm excited I don't know where this is
going
yeah I can't I mean King Gary Brooke
before I don't I can't fake it
yeah that's the problem all the way here
and you're not even ready to take
exactly sure that's okay so I'm hanging
up three here King here and a good boy
King e 2.3 yeah that can be three but it
doesn't matter like you get here and
you're not even threatening to take the
knight at all exactly
okay so again unless he's got a lot of
time that's that's also very important
in the yes blade move gd6 gd6 magnus
trying to keep it as difficult as
possible
Wesley still has to prove he understands
yes or Sarah wands an optimal
coordination no he's got this this is
that this is in the bag date as they say
another idea here is actually kind of
nice for white how about rook a one so I
don't know okay go ahead Danny pretty
second okay rook a one King a five King
f3 now what this means is you can't play
King before because maybe the Avon is
really really really fast although it's
a funny line if you play a move like
this and then you go back together
run and now I've chased your pawn and
you you've coax my opponent of copepods
you know no I think it's a win kingi for
King you get ninety four and then you
get 96 yes and you can't take the pawn
after King b6l and then I get 98 yes
even then I see a solid ice Oh your turn
okay so Brooke a one might work but
again one that work as well
seems that now king of three rook a one
and rook c1 probably all win
I suspect that even here if you got
rooked before if it was black to move
and he could play rook before probably
still be wouldn't uh yeah I suspect so
that the King will just marched over and
I'm saying I think that the other way to
look at it is you've actually
established the goal you need with the
knight being protected who protects the
pawn and you don't really need to
improve the rook yeah it's ugly as it
looks right and it's a temporary thing
so we're thinking that King f3 King a5
King III it's good enough as well
man he's raised his eyebrows on King g3
he's done it he invited oh by the way
now Wesley is gonna move a tempo Wesley
said a beautiful trap did you see that
is that trap Wesley was hoping for
rook B for 10 days and then I sit for
exact and then take the 85 yes exactly
Magnus can fall for the king b5 is just
frozen yeah it's okay
Magnus plays rook t4 but this was a nice
idea by Wesley because now you gain
another tempo exactly so you gain one
tempo which maybe doesn't matter but
king of three King III in a second
temple way over I love gaining Tempe and
any kind of attending in any kind of
ending you know like these king upon
endings you know where you think
everything wins no no no no no ain't a
tempo winning the tempo take it get a
nice view of West the back of Wesley's
here there no Wesley does Wesley have
rook d1 by the way rookie 1 any reasons
that that might rock before and then a
check on d6
could I just see that I thinking f3 yeah
yeah why yeah because after check and
now I'll check again and now we have a
sense it's better just to bring the King
across King f3 key me three or as we've
seen yes he's done it yeah yep three
King game 5 and now King III right
the nepali aashiq are wanting game is it
still way going I mean how could it be
going out to stop the bleeding perhaps
with a victory that's if your view one
of the greatest games we're not going to
render again this is if you if you're
just tuning in this was a rather
brilliant performance by Wesley so to
get here assuming he converts the kind
of attack that you the master of
understatement rather brilliant is a way
to say something is like flippin awesome
like we've been flipping on one idea if
I bring my king to c3 then I can play 94
and you cannot take pawn because rook
before mate exactly yeah yeah yeah
Wesley's rook finally finds freedom by
the way threat rook h5 to be 500
defending the knight in a really really
good way so for example rook b8 probably
he has to play now you mean if he play
if he stays on defiled and I can still
rock h5 rugby 5 yes do you can have any
place d7 sorry I was so pious on the
lightboard I forgot okay so rook h1 so
here's a cute line by Wesley rook H 1
rupee eggs King oh let me check King
before King D 2 king a3 rupee 5 and this
is your check main idea rook da check
yeah King said really and rook c8 94
precisely rook see a check night C 4
check King and what a finish that way
yeah I mean a a almost a perfect finish
for ya extraordinary game yeah Magnus is
not have a definite
by the way again Wesley
oh now 94-96 very very nice taken he's
also just immediately threatening Brooke
d4 nicely winning on the spot that's
like let the king in and the game is
over and seriously that looked at Wesley
just yeah that way that's Wesley finally
knows he's winning look he knows he's
got this in the bag all right yeah no
you can bring the king to d3 no it's no
more but no more magic tricks actually
yes it's seven minutes just on his clock
I mean with no delay no delay it's a
good boy no delay no increments yes so I
will play it till the end till you made
me like is the world major happily
happily makes you so now rook c4 c4 c3
exactly what amazing can take here right
now by Wesley almost see the goods
delivering the goods oh sorry I meant to
say Kings you okay you can put the king
of b3 block on c3 with the rook make c4
so he finally has optimal coordination
exactly and we're gonna have drama here
in Norway are we because the the
reigning world champion in hometown hero
Magnus Carlsen will be behind by three
three points yes that's a lot
this is we're pretty much able to call
it now because yeah this is Wow so
Wesley also sorry we were just too
quickly just flashing that's it it's
interesting yeah we're going back okay
this is where the drama is right here as
a pattern recognition if I gave you a
chess set now how many pieces which
could you
I got a volley put I got a wall I think
well you know makes 95-96 night of seven
he ordered a plate
King he's a white King g4 pawn h5 no no
no no there's no y kinky for no
no wait wait wait a brass justice okay
hy Vikings on each one there was
something running far now we'll see now
let's look ah d4 okay okay yeah we're
doing calculation this is uh okay now
he's set up for night c4 check what whoa
what what happened oh you feel me oh
what a funny mood the medium responses
is a dgt relayer
right rook takes c6 would be probably
for check one of the greatest howlers or
night c4 exactly and yeah
so Magnus frustrated but gonna play this
thing out again if we're talking about
time it's still drama here because
remember no delay no increment so what
you see is what you get and even the
fastest players probably lose at least a
second
yeah the physical mobility of tonight's
support come on
yes 94 ok chuan where the idea came
before I guess he played all right check
check back to 18 for so now your king
can go to the a5 square very nicely yeah
so just nice inks rip g6 oh yeah yeah
then can get you 5 or 7 exactly
young he's done it and by the way
threader 47 now there are serious check
mating patterns to because you can win
rook at night versus rook with certain
checkmating matters the they're already
close enough Nepal Miyagi has won by the
way our congratulations to young but how
is it actually I I can't get the ace I
can't get their opponent night versus
kinguin it's know when it's nice for
black yeah like Ruby g7 rook b7 let's
say then I don't have gone on there are
some now science tale mating ideas you
have two examples nice like put a night
on b6 right right please play that
native to show everybody here for King
a6 oh and for the record at this point
it would be a draw
even on a move like this yeah here is
live but ok Magnus Carlsen resigns
because Wesley I am just not allow this
yeah like that was a phenomenal Wow own
epic nante one yes Wesley so comes up
with a huge victory welcome to the
Fisher random World Championship what
around of rhino I mean wow yep I love to
the game this game was this game thumb
is gonna let it play in the background
while we sit here and talk over and over
but this was just um
just a great a fantastic game from start
to finish it was original right from the
get-go
had us kind of curious about what
structure they get ultimately became
very Queen's Gambit ish yeah and we were
all a little surprised here in the
transition middle game that Wesley maybe
didn't get more on the Queen side I
almost felt like he was settling
eventually with the f3 e4 plan but then
no but the decisions he took all this
age 3 F 3 F word
it was brilliant yeah it turns out
exactly what he and to do keeping the
bishop on c1 and guess what like this
idea yeah not wasting the Bishop e3
tempo
a lot of vision there to understand that
eventually he should be okay right there
well I have to say I appreciate rookie
495 rookie for Bishop age 698 all of
these moves I the the line I've come up
with it's like riding a tiger both
guides there's no way you could
calculate this to the end
they were just calculating and playing
the moves all the tempo but again whole
thing this whole movie should be six was
great Bishop takes she said but this was
the move that just Wesley so is
currently down a rook in the position
but a friend all kinds of checkmates
well he's threatening to check in the
Royal fork on e7 because the king would
be a Riven into the into the royal floor
but like like a lot of good attacks all
it does is get him a better endgame and
in the end the ends of converting though
really taking advantage of one mistake
by Magnus which was this move rookie to
allowing me falling for it suddenly East
7 becomes available for business how
costly was that yep white wins a piece
and Wesley calculates Knight b6 and just
yet ultimately knew he was winning here
took him a second try to get it right
and he did it he did it he brought the
king over and uh just again just showing
the final moments here the World Chess
Champion does not lose very often he
hasn't lost a classical game and you
know God weird a 25 years 101 games he
loses this game and now trails in the
fish of random World Chess Championship
title match let's bring up the scores
remind everybody where we stand after
both of these games four and a half one
and a half yeah and it is four and a
half one and a half for Wesley so three
points deadlocked there between Fabiano
car wanna yonder pump Yoshi in the
bronze medal match if you will but we're
gonna take a very quick break when we
come back more action possibly
interviews we're gonna break down the de
pomme Miasha Caruana game make sure we
don't miss anything there so don't go
anywhere the world Fisher random Chess
Championship continues and we